gilbert collard bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour commencer au delà de la question
des causes un des flux migratoires
comment selon vous l'europe la france en
particulier doit gérer ces situations
d'urgence face à des personnes en péril
sur des embarcations de fortune qu'est
ce qu'on fait d'abord un essai départ
confondre navire publicitaire avec
navire humanitaire là si j'ose dire les
masses que ton il est clair qu'on a
affaire à une opération politique à
l'infirmière en chef en charge à bord
les questions sanitaires a déclaré
elle-même qu'il s'agissait d'abord d'une
question je cite damnation anarchiste on
est donc bien dans une dans une démarche
complètement politique qui prend
quelques pas en otage les les migrants
pour en faire des produits de pression
médiatique
au risque de mettre en danger en péril
leur vie comme ce fut le cas hélas pour
l'un d'entre eux et au risque de menacer
leur sécurité
donc il faut être lucide on n'a pas
affaire à des humanitaires on a affaire
à des politiciens publicitaires qui se
sert des migrants du chantage à
l'émotion légitime du chantage à
l'inquiétude légitime pour exercer une
communication et des pressions sur les
gouvernements
la réaction d'abord exiger l'application
du droit international maritime ensuite
saisir et systématiquement les bateaux
qui transportent dans des conditions
illégales délit grand mais manière que
l'instrument l'instrument financier qui
est le bateau et qui doit aussi à mon
avis bien l'aider des passeurs soit
immobilisé saisies et vendues
gilbert collard très concrètement face à
ces situations d'urgence qu'est ce que
vous proposez moi je propose
systématiquement par la force des choses
de venir en aide aux migrants qui exerce
un chantage à la pitié au cas par cas
les renvoyer et saisir chaque fois le
bateau et procéder à sa vente
le bateau est l'instrument du chantage
il faut pas tomber dans le panneau
là on voit bien qu'on a affaire à une
opération politique quand vous pensez
qu'à bord du louise michel
seules les femmes en droit à la parole
bon ça les regarde c'est leur droit mais
ça montre quand même qu'on est con et à
bord d'un bateau qui fait beaucoup plus
de cas de la politique que des migrants
les migrants sont devenus maintenant un
instrument de communication politique
sur base de chantage affectif hopper
peuple qui n'en peuvent plus qui n'en
peuvent plus regarder à lampedusa a
regardé un peu partout autour de vous là
la question des migrants est devenue une
question qui qui absorbe complètement
toutes les questions le souci matériel
le souci géographique partout dans dans
toute l'europe qui a des cas des rivages
c'est la question qui revient
constamment
ne tombons pas dans le piège du chantage
à l'émotion
gilbert verrait gilbert que là vous
parlez d'une situation au cas par cas
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
qu'est ce que ça comment est-ce qu'on
sélectionne tous ceux qui ne sont pas
des réfugiés politiques repartent et je
dirais même que systématiquement comme
l'ailé
les migrants entre guillemets qui sont à
bord de ses bateaux n'ont aucun titre
préexistant à accoster
on devrait les accompagner vers les eaux
les plus proches se dire l'application
du droit international et leur
destination légal mais on cède devant
chantage en scène parce que comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure à
l'introduction
c'est une affaire humanitaires mais
réalité en réalité c'est un
humanitarisme homicide
un migrant est mort à bord du bateau
d'émigrants été blessés en définitive on
se sert de la vie de ces hommes et ces
femmes beaucoup d'hommes du reste très
peu de femmes pour exercer une
communication politique
là c'est une espèce de mouvement
anarchiste féministes qui le dit du
reste il s'en cachent même plus qui se
sert des migrants pour d'une part faire
connaître faire connaître aussi quand
même au passage
l'artiste qui investit dans une
publicité flottante
on a affaire à des à des gens sordide
quoi qui exploitent la misère humaine et
qui exploitent la la faiblesse d'aidé
des pouvoirs qui n'ont pas le courage de
dire que nous on n'entre pas dans le
chantage affectif
on marche pas vous ne devez pas rentrer
vous ne devez pas accoster en vous
rappelle et si vous accosté de toute
manière le bateau sera saisi et vendu la
ville de marseille s'est dit disposé à
accueillir le navire louise-michel vous
en pensez quoi c'est le rôle de la
france de venir en aide à ces à ces
personnes en péril
mais le problème c'est qu'on ne vient
pas en aide
on on justifie une mise en scène en
venant en aide
les conditions de l'appel au secours
sont créés sont fabriqués très souvent
et s'il y a nécessité de venir en aide
il faut venir en aide mais il faut à ce
moment là qu'il y ait des sanctions
immédiates qui fera le bateau c'est à
dire les commanditaires saisie et vente
du navire parce que on est dans
l'illégalité la plus absolue
la violation du droit international
maritime la plus totale et on n'a pas de
raison de supporter des comportements
sous prétexte que bien évidemment on ne
peut pas reculer devant le secours on
n'a pas de
zend supporter d'accepter ce chantage
qui est absolument absolument écoeurant
et du coup c'est à l'europe d'assurer
une présence en méditerranée justement
pour éviter ce genre de drame mais il ya
bien longtemps que l'europe aurait dû
faire la police de la police maritime et
la chasse à ces bateaux et les saisir
j'ai imaginé que l'on procède à la
saisie et à la vende textes légaux à
l'appui de tous ces bateaux qui amène en
frob
quand même le rappeler des migrants qui
n'ont aucun titre juridique
je sais que ça a plus beaucoup
d'importance dans une haie périodes où
c'est l'atmosphère qui fait la loi et
non pas la loi qui fait le texte
mais si on saisit c'est systématiquement
les bateaux croyez moi il y en aura de
moins en moins mais donc pour vous
l'action que ces ong elle n'est pas
louable pour gérer des situations
dramatiques mais elle organise la
situation dramatique
le migrant qui est mort à bord du bateau
il est mort à bord du bateau
les blessés dont étaient à bord du
bateau à partir du moment où un équipage
prends cette responsabilité d'embarquer
à son bord des hommes essentiellement
qui vont par la force de l'émotion
vouloir accoster tout l'équipage c'est
qui fait prendre des risques aux
passagers tout l'équipage sait qu'il va
être dans l'obligation de faire appel à
des secours qui déclencheront le cor de
chasse médiatique et ils auront à ce
moment là le beau rôle et ceux qui
liront m'attendais les populations n'en
peuvent plus les les villes d'accueil et
vous allez voir marseille à ce que ça va
comment ça va dégénérer si ça continue
bon ceux qui disent attention il faut
quand même une loi de pondération des
ddd contraire ce
yd il faut éviter que ça dégénère que
les populations non 98 sommes plus en
guerre ont l'air de salon alors qu en
définitive on crée un un contexte ce
préfabriqué dans lequel il ya d'un côté
les belles âmes qui aura lutté sont des
âmes tricoter fabriquer un inventé
politique et de l'autre les méchants qui
voudraient pas accueillir ce que l'on
veut leur imposer qui pourrait très bien
dur est allé dans d'autres pays la
tunisie l'algérie le maroc l'egypte
voilà mais on se garde bien d'aller vers
ces eaux là un merci beaucoup gilbert
collard d'avoir répondu à nos questions
rappelle que vous êtes député européen
du rassemblement national